personally if you were to be diagnosed
with some form of cancer how would you
treat yourself personally would you use
the standard of care with chemotherapy
depending on what cancer it is and how
would you alter your lifestyle in your
diet it's a bit of a loaded question I
know sorry no I'm glad I guess I get
asked this question a lot it really
comes down to the type of cancer like I
know friends and colleagues of mine kind
of feel that cancer is sort of you know
all one disease and I think there's a
lot of truth to that but also understand
that you know I have people that are
close to me that have cancers for
example leukemia acute myeloid leukemia
as an example I knew people with
multiple myeloma lymphoma testicular
cancer had one or two or three students
or three people that I know responded
very well to the standard of care and
some of them did the KJ diet some so it
really depends on the type type of
cancer we I got into this looking at
brain cancer so it made sense to me
because I realize oh brain cancer
patients have seizures and they're on
heavy doses of anti-seizure drugs
sometimes but they're also put on
something called dexamethasone which is
a corticosteroid that really disrupts
your metabolism and elevate your glucose
in a way that's feeding the cancer these
corticosteroids do so I thought the
ketogenic diet could be used for that
and then the more I started looking to
it I saw that Thomas Seyfried had
published that a calorie restricted
ketogenic diet targeted tumor metabolism
in a way that was highly efficacious at
least in animal models so so it really
I'm just saying that's because it really
depends on the type of cancers a couple
reviews have been written about the
types of cancers so things that are
really metabolically demanding cancers
and these are cancers that would show up
on a PET scan and fdg-pet scan so if
someone has
a type of tumor a solid tumor in
particular that's really hot on a PET
scan and that means that it's sucking up
massive amounts of glucose relative to
the healthy tissue surrounding it so
what a ketogenic strategy does and it
could be used as an adjuvant to the
standard of care is that its lowers
glucose availability to the tumor and
most tumors really have accelerated
glucose metabolism and that's driven in
part by insulin and insulin signaling
like igf-1 the pi3 kinase Akt mTOR
pathway I don't want to go down that
road but it's activated it's driven by
glucose insulin and the insulin sort of
pathway right so if we suppress the
hormone insulin we can do that with
nutritional ketosis especially if it's
calorie restricted that basically is
knocking down a major driver of most
cancers like it's it's pretty safe to
say that I would say 80% or more cancers
are really driven by this pi3 kinase Akt
mTOR pathway when these pathways are
hyper activated and insulin being a
driver for that it accelerates cancer
growth and proliferation so one way to
take the foot off the gas gas pedal of
this cancer growth and proliferation is
to knock down the prime one of the main
pathways accelerating it which is which
is insulin and how do we knock down
insulin through carbohydrate restriction
and to some extent protein restriction
also fasting intermittent fasting where
we go through periods of time restricted
eating so if we were to do this prior to
the standard of care like chemotherapy
or radiation
it makes the tumors more vulnerable to
modalities that kill through what we
call an oxidative stress mechanism so if
you limit glucose availability to a
tumor and if you're in a fasted state
the tumors ability to create its own
antioxidants glutathione being a major
one is a bit impaired so you can enhance
the cancer killing effects of chemo and
radiation if the patient is in a a
fasted state or on a ketogenic diet we
also think that hyperbaric oxygen
therapy which increases the partial
pressure of oxygen in the tissues and
thereby also enhances oxidative stress
and the oxidative stress is higher in
cancer cells because of the aberrant
mitochondria that they have they spit
out more of something called superoxide
in response to increasing levels of
oxygen relative to normal cells so
you'll have enhanced oxidative stress in
cancer cells also more free heme and
when you it creates it dry something
called the Fenton reaction you don't
need to know that but listeners may be
familiar with these pathways but it
creates a scenario where oxidative
stress is higher just by using something
that's relatively non-toxic like
hyperbaric oxygen therapy within defined
limits and then if you give radiation or
chemo that could enhance the efficacy of
that especially in the context of a
ketogenic diet so radiation and chemo
could essentially boost the effects of
hyperbaric treatment yeah well the
efficacy of radiation is proportional to
the po2 of the tumor right so if you
radiate a tumor that's hypoxic the
radiation killing effect of the tumor
will be dependent on molecular oxygen
that's inside the tumor so if you hyper
oxygenate a tumor or if you reverse
tumor hypoxia because a lot of tumors
they grow so fast that outstrips their
ability the the vascular church can't
keep up with the expanding biomass so
the the inside of the tumor the core of
the tumor becomes anoxic or hypoxic but
if you with hyperbaric oxygen the oxygen
is transferred to the tumor not by blood
vessels but it's in plasma hemoglobins
already saturated so it gets oxygen to
the plasma and then you hyperox Fernet
the tumor reverse the tumor hypoxia and
then apply the the stimulus the killing
stimulus so that could be chemotherapy
it could be radiation it could be immune
based drug to we call this the press
pulse theory so if you google like
press pulse theory and a publication
nutrition metabolism this idea that you
create a stress on the cancer cells by
nutritional ketosis drugs like metformin
intermittent fasting exercise meditation
things like that creates an environment
that compromises the tumors ability to
grow or decreases its ability to grow
being in a fasted State will also make
the tumor more vulnerable by weakening
its antioxidant defenses and and also
suppressing certain growth pathways that
ps3 kinase pathway and then and then
other modalities will work better so
that could be hyperbaric oxygen therapy
could be used but chemo radiation and
immune based therapies too will be more
efficacious in the context of a press so
a press and then a pulse therapy can be
delivered ideally like two or three
weeks on you know three weeks off
something like that it depends on the
particular agents but there's also
metabolic drugs that can be used to and
some of these drugs are toxic like 2d
oxy glucose 3 Burma pyruvate Luneta mean
these are things that target the
glycolytic pathways ok and we use these
sort of these things experimentally but
I think what patients who are listening
maybe can go and look up the press pulse
concept and we just basically put a
paper out as a concept here's an idea we
are working with different people that
are moving this into the clinic and some
people are just doing it because right
now there's no not a whole lot of
clinical trials that are incorporating
this although I have to say that when I
started studying this the ketogenic diet
there was maybe two clinical trials and
now I looked this morning before coming
there was 39 clinical trials yeah and
about many of them are ongoing or
recruiting to Soho Wow so now these are
you know many of them a lot of them are
top to your Institute's like doing
things and then I looked up fasting I
never like went onto clinical trials.gov
and putting cancer and then fasting and
like hundreds of trials came up not all
of them are relevant but there was
dozens of trials looking at the effects
of fasting
before chemo and radiation many the
first like couple were using the fasting
mimicking diet
so Valter Longo who's on the west coast
developed a diet that essentially used
five days per month and it's a hypo
caloric diet that puts the body into a
state of ketosis mild ketosis and and
this type of diet can be used in
conjunction with standard of care and
it's a it's sort of a commercialized
version of a ketogenic diet and it's
mostly plant-based so it has some unique
aspects to it one could formulate their
own ketogenic diet or their own fasting
mimicking diet just by going to the
grocery store and and formulating the
foods so so the science is is really
ongoing and it's emerging but to have
dozens of registered clinical trials
looking at the effects of fasting and
cancer as a means to enhance standard of
care and and patients should also if
they're interested in being part of
these clinical trials clinical
trials.gov that's the basically the site
that has a registered clinical trials so
look up ketogenic diet and then your
whatever cancer you have whether it be
lung cancer endometrial cancer liver
cancer or something like that so look up
to see if maybe a clinical trials in
your area and you might be you know
might be able to participate in that
when they talk about the hyperbaric
oxygen treatment did they use those like
tube things that like LeBron James gets
into after his basketball games where he
lays down and like it's kinda like a
coffin shaped tube yeah that with the
user that that would be that's a mono
placed chamber okay yeah so that that
could be one of ways there's also a
multi place chamber that you could use
but if you go to a hyperbaric oxygen
clinic what they may do is most of these
clinics actually there there's 14
different fda-approved applications for
a hyperbaric oxygen therapy oh really
one is decompression sickness if you're
a diver you know you come up with the
bends you go inside a hyperbaric chamber
the other is for I mean there's there's
a lot but the top ones would be diabetic
wounds so wounds people who have
diabetes their blood is like sludge
they're not getting enough oxygen and
nutrition to the wound so it begins to
fester and grow and hyperbaric oxygen
therapy hyper oxygenates to wound a
wound is hypoxic and the energy levels
in that tissue are knocked down by like
90% so hyperbaric oxygen therapy can
restore metabolism we also believe if
you put someone on a ketone supplement
or and one of my students dr. Shannon
Kessel did her PhD dissertation on the
effects of nutritional ketosis and wound
healing and is remarkably effective
enhancing the wound healing process Wow
and we think if you couple it with
hyperbaric oxygen it would be you know
diabetic wounds or chronic wounds it's
like a multi multi-billion dollar health
problem right now that people have
typically would type 2 diabetes but
people have bed sores right like these
wounds they don't heal nutritional
ketosis is one so hyperbaric oxygen is
used for that and so you have multi
place chambers you can get in you go in
you read a book you listen to music
sometimes the walls of the chamber are
transparent so you can see what's going
on in the room and then you have a multi
placed chamber where you get inside the
chamber it's pressurized to like say 2
or 2.5 atmospheres
at hyperbaric air and then you put the
mask on and that's 100% oxygen and you
breathe that mask and then you reach
hyperbaric oxygen therapy levels you
take the mask off so if you have a
seizure you can take the mask off and
then you go from hyperbaric oxygen to
hyperbaric air which the partial
pressure P the po2 will be low enough
that you won't have a seizure is that
sense yeah that make sense
so we're breathing 20 percent oxygen now
a hyperbaric oxygen chamber you were
breathing in a mono place chamber you're
breathing a hundred percent oxygen
typically or thereabouts and when you
get inside a multi place chamber it's 20
percent oxygen but you put the mask on
that becomes 100 cent oxygen and
hemoglobin is already saturated right
but the oxygen gets into the plasma and
that's the benefit to wound healing
that's the benefit to attacking a tumor
is that tumor vasculature is like
erratic and not very good so the tumor
becomes hypoxic but if it's in the
may can penetrate that tumor oh wow and
then oxygen can kick on reactive oxygen
species that can start to kill the tumor
inside out and then you apply most
chemotherapeutic drugs kill cancer cells
through an oxidative stress mechanism so
if you've already you know cause
oxidative stress and you apply oxy
platen or cisplatin or something like
that and then radiation too then you
have like it creates a lot more die off
on the tumor okay that and then being in
ketosis will protect your healthy cells
and also sensitize the tumor cells to
more so that was sort of you know some
of the first publications that we did
when people are following up on that
well it's amazing how many more studies
have come out and how many how do you
mean the clinical trials you were saying
either yeah the clinical trials is
really Meehan's amazing you know we're
not doing any because we're more of a
basic science but people look at the
research that we're doing and they say
hey you know just some people give us a
heads-up and like you know your your
research kind of inspired this clinical
trial other people were doing this
research to dr. Thomas Seyfried was a
huge pioneer and I just followed in his
footsteps and just used his model system
Luke Antley is doing some work with the
ketogenic diet and targeting this pi3
kinase pathway with different drugs dr.
Adrian Scheck she was at Barrow
Neurological Institute is really a
pioneer in glioblastoma which is the
deadly form of brain cancer and her work
has inspired you know the Barrow
Neurological Institute and the lead
clinician there Chris Smith to sort of
advocate that patients with glioblastoma
glioblastoma followed the ketogenic diet
prior to them coming in and having
surgery because it helps shrink the
tumor and makes it a smaller target that
they can resect it and they get better
outcomes you know after after surgery -
so I've been communicating with some of
those patients
[Laughter]